cette étape la plus attendue a donc
commencé dans le drap jo lisez avec ce
matin la chute mortelle de fabio
casartelli 25 ans champion olympique à
barcelone récit laurent frédéric bollée
immobile est pratiquement déjà sans vie
fabio casartelli j ai même le sol dans
une mare de sang
à ses côtés d'autres coureurs impliqués
dans une chute terrible on est au 34e km
de la 15e étape du tour de france
au détour d'un virage de la descente du
portet d'aspet le drame a frappé
manifestement l'italien a heurté une des
bornes en béton qui longe la route le
choc le plonge alors immédiatement dans
un coma profond
difficile de savoir ce qui s'est
vraiment passé écart crevaison fautes en
tout cas sans casque sous la chaleur
aujourd'hui casartelli ne se relèvera
pas il avait fêté son 25e anniversaire
il y a deux jours les secours pourtant
sont arrivés très vite
soigné sur place puis évacuée par
hélicoptère casartelli sur la victime de
trois arrêts cardiaques pendant son
transfert le décès sera prononcée
officiellement à 14 heures également
touchés dans l'accident l'allemand
baldinger et l'italien périgny souffrent
de traumatismes divers
quant aux français de reins' il a plongé
dans le ravin et s'est blessé gravement
à la cuisse gauche
professionnelle depuis deux ans
casartelli le premier coureur à décéder
sur le tour depuis tony simpson en 67
on se souviendra de lui comme le
champion olympique en titre de la
spécialité en 92 à barcelone il avait
triomphé et avait offert à tous les
observateurs un visage rayonnant à
l'image de sa jeunesse pleine d'avenir